Хто кому потрібніший:
Україна Саакашвілі чи Саакашвілі Україні?
Про це ми будемо говорити з самим політиком
у нього удома. Дуже дякую за те, що
в нас є можливість з Вами поговорити.
Ми перебуваємо в передмісті Києва.
До речі, що це за будинок?
Це маленький будинок, який ми, моя родина, почали будувати
десь три роки тому. Я вважав, що це закінчиться
через три місяці, тому що... Ну, що тут будувати?
Але це, як будівництво нової України.
Це тривало і тривало, і перебудовували,
і крали, і брехали.
А в мене не було часу.
Так сталося, що замість кількох тижнів -
майже три роки.
І  закінчилося в той день, коли я приїхав до Києва.
Можливо, і в Україні не усі "за" те, що Ви приїхали.
І, зокрема, останнім часом
було багато коментарів з приводу висловлювання
президента РФ Володимира Путіна,
шо він нібито запропонував пану Зеленському - новому президенту України -
видати Вам паспорт....
Це був такий тролінг...
Я  взагалі улюблений персонаж Володимира  Путіна.
Він не може без мене довго існувати.
Щоразу щось про мене згадує.
І коли він пояснював росіянам, чому
опозиція в Росії не потрібна, він казав:
"ви що, хочете, щоб Саакашвілі бігали по Росії?"
Щоб багато "саакашвілі". бігали по Уралу, по Сибіру, по Москві,
по інших містах.
Путін, звичайно, через різні канали
надсилав сигнал Володимиру Зеленському,
що це є тест,
Якщо мені дозволять повернутися в Україну,
то це означає, що Зеленський - не зовсім те,
на що сподіваються в Москві.
Зеленський це зробив. І для мне це є доказ,
що він справді незалежна людина від Москви
незалежна від місцевих тут
олігархічних інтересів. Наприклад, Труханов ...
Навіщо йому потрібно, щоб я був в Україні?
Я розумію, що зараз у Вас високий кредит довіри
до нового президента України.
Але за яких умов Ви почнете нещадно критикувати нову владу?
Це було б і для мене особистою  трагедією.
Чому? Бо у нас було два шанси -
після першого Майдану і після другого Майдану. Якщо Україна втратить третій шанс,
мені здається, що України, можливо,
в теперішньому вигляді взагалі не буде.
Тож це не питання політичної критики.
Якщо я побачу, що втрачається час…
Час нині дуже обмежений. Дуже.
Зараз немає багато часу і багато місця для маневрів.
Тому що вся ця еліта, вона
чітко відчуває загрозу.
Ну подивіться, що вони роблять!
Вони реально весь час маневрують, щоб
Зеленський  згаяв час
і щоб вони вдарили
у влучний для них момент.
І не треба їм надавати цей момент!
Ви казали, що не маєте жодних політичних амбіцій.
Але як це Ви можете пояснити ?
Дуже просто
Якщо подивитися на Вашу біографію, в це важко повірити.
Мені здається, що зараз
настає час великих ідей.
Україні потрібен прорив.
А прорив можливий лише тоді, якщо Україна відмовиться
від тих державних традицій, які створилися за останні 30 років.
На 100% відмовиться.
І хто має більше шансів це зробити, як не людина,
яка є абсолютно несистемною? Зеленський - він реально несистемний.
І якщо не він, то
реально ніхто інший не зможе. Тому зараз я хочу -
моя контрибуція буде, мій внесок буде
в площині генерування цих ідей.
Зробити майданчик, де я зможу
разом з іншими людьми, з молоддю,
зможу поділитися досвідом
моїх успіхів і невдалих експериментів, особливо в Україні.
І генерувати, створювати нові ідеї для розвитку.
І все ж таки, чи хочете Ви бути в уряді?
- Ні.
- …щоб втілити в життя свої ідеї?
Я повернувся в країну,
яка дуже відрізняється від тієї, яку я залишив.
Щойно відбулася електоральна революція. Що це означає?
Два місяці тому багато фігур в українській політиці
вони вважалися "вічними".
араз вони поводяться і реально почуваються як "зомбі".
У них нема землі під ногами зараз.
І це унікальна ситуація,
і тому мені треба поспілкуватися, почути...
Таке враження, що не тільки я не до кінця не розумію,
але і більшість людей тут також не розуміють, що все змінилося.
Усе інакше. Всі старі підходи і мій
старий підхід застаріли, вони не спрацюють.
Тому треба бути обережнішим ,
не бути під впливом цих стереотипів в українській політиці.
Незабаром відбудуться парламентські вибори. Чи буде Ваша партія "Рух нових сил" брати в них участь?
Зараз "Слуга народу" забере більшість цього парламенту.
Вони отримають чітку більшість. Я не бачу конкуренції зараз.
Залишиться меншість з частиною проросійського лекторату.
Є інші старі політики, які зараз перебувають в глибокій кризі.
Є маленька ніша, ще залишається для нових політиків.
Не знаю, чи зараз я і наша політсила здатні дуже швидко її зайняти. Не знаю.
Ви проти олігархів. Ви проти корупції.
Але багато хто в Україні каже, що що президент Зеленський -
це майже рівнозначно олігарх Коломойський.
В мене немає такого враження. Все дуже просто.
Зеленський - це не така людина, яка схоче бути тінню когось іншого.
Не варто недооцінювати олігарха Коломойського. Він дуж е сильна особистість. І це не тільки гроші.
Реально він дуже контроверсійна, але сильна особистість. Проте Зеленський також дуже сильний
Він "selfmade". І він вирішить це, він не олігархічний проект.
Якщо поглянути на його біографію, то в Зеленського немає постійних алянсів.
Він набрав багато людей:
таких як Олександр Данилюк, як Айварас Абромавичус, як Сергій Лещенко.
Коли Айварас був міністром економіки, він був найгіршим ворогом, -
ну, я теж був, - але він в уряді був найгрішим ворогом для всіх олігархів.
Ви сказали, що не прагнете помсти екс-президенту Петру Порошенку
за те, що Вас позбавили громадянства.
Але ми знаємо про позови до МВС, до інших правоохоронців.
І керівництво там залишається старим. Як Ви вважаєте, що буде далі?
Усіх їх дуже швидко змінять. Це перше. Друге, що стосується Порошенко.
Так, я не людина, яка повернулася сюди мститися. Я приїхав до свого дому, друзів та близьких.
Помста чи чиїсь арешти - це не моя функція.
Моя функція будувати те, що я добре вмію. Я вмію будувати.
Але якщо Україна створить прецедент, як Бразілія, як Південна Корея,
що президент, який реально крав, - і це не якісь політичні переслідування, -
і реально був покараний...
А тут крали у військових. Це найгірша форма крадіжки. Я це лише вітатиму.
Бо для України це стало б відповіддю за багато каденцій принижень і знущань над народом.
Як Ви будете захищатися, якщо згадаємо, що Ваші стосунки з керівництвом МВС були не дуже добрі?
Особистого конфлікта з Арсеном Аваковим в мене не було. Це так збоку виглядало.
Це був конфлікт з системою, а він нав той момент захищав систему і зараз продовжує її захищати.
Тож особистої образи на Авакова у мене немає. Вона є більше на Порошенка. Чому?
Порошенко давав обіцянки.
"Обіцянки-цяцянки, а дурнику радість.." Саме це в нас з ним вийшло.
Тож я маю підстави ображатися на Порошенка, але які підстави ображатися на Авакова?
Система має змінитися, з усіма людьми, які були в системі!
Ви постійно розповідаєте про те, що Ви вмієте будувати.
Але Ви не точно кажете, що саме хочете збудувати в Україні?
Зеленський хоче перенести адміністрацію з Банкової.
А я хочу перетворити цю ідею на те, щоб взагалі адміністративні центри винести з Києва.
Кудись туди - в передмістя Києва або в чисте поле десь у Черкаській області.
І створити абсолютно новий адміністративний центр.
До речі, коли запитують, звідки ми знайдемо гроші, то це дуже просто!
Продаєш всі ці будинки і десь 20-30% отриманих грошей
вистачить на будівництво нового адміністративного центру.
А якщо скоротити адміністративний апарат десь в тричі,
то можна приблизно утричі збільшити їм зарплати та підвижити вимоги до них.
Якщо в Україні почнуться такі зміни і я братиму в них участь, тоді я зрозумію, що я успішний.
Після вашого видворення з України чи думали Ви над тим, яких помилок Ви припустилися?
Було багато помилок. Тому що реально Порошенко
змусив мене своїми теж досить брутальними діями
чи відсутністю будь-яких позитивних дійрадикалізуватися.
І наприкінці я був занадто радикальним. Але ситуація і виклики були теж радикальними.
Для мене це не дуже гарна роль. Мене запитують, чому я виглядаю спокійнішим, обережнішим.
Так, я спокійніший. Я не обережний, а спокійніший.
Зараз я значно спокійніший, ніж коли я бігав дахами. Чому?
Тому що тоді всі були на даху, реально... Зараз з'явився шанс.
В Борисполі, коли ви прилетіли, було багато телекамер. Усі стрімили, усі знімали.
Чи трапились Вам на шляху з Варшави до Києва якісь телекомпанії, яким Ви відмовили?
На польському кордоні до мене причепилися російські телекомпанії.
І моя відповідь була така, що, мовляв, хлопці і дівчата!
Як би ви не знущалися над ідеєю України, але вона щойно обрала абсолютного аутсайдера - людину,
яка дуже відрізняється від усіх політиків.
Ось коли у вас оберуть коміка на кшталт Михайла Галустяна,
тоді я вас привітаю і з превеликим задоволенням буду з Вами спілкуватися,
тому що тоді ви будете вільні.
Вони намагалися подарувати мені червону краватку.
Це в них такі старі жарти, бо нових немає, в них взагалі криза.
Я казав, що можна помазати краватку "Новачком" і відправити Володимиру Володимировичу.
Звичайно, вони не пустить це в ефір. Ну... а як? Як на це реагувати?
Чи збираєтесь Ви перевозити свою родину сюди?
Так, так.
Пані Сандру?
Вони спостерігали за всім цим по телевізору.
Вони до кінця не вірили, що мені не перешкоджатимуть в'їхати.
Ми всі вже звикли, що поки лише проблеми.
І це уперше, коли все пройшло просто на "ура".
Якщо коротко, то, все ж, хто кому більше потрібен: Україна Вам, чи Ви Україні?
Я б хотів, щоб не тільки Україна була мені потрібна. Бо це усім зрозуміло.
Мені вона дуже потрібна.
Але щоб настав час, коли 10% українців теж скажуть, - чи 20%,
чи в ідеалі 30%, - що ось цей грузин нам теж потрібен. Так що ось так.
Дуже дякую.
Дякую Вам.